so it looks like Marvel Studios might be
changing their entire plans for
Spider-Man 4 if some recent reports are
true and this is going to be due to
several reasons which of course we'll go
over in this video but one of the main
reasons that Spiderman 4 might change is
because Andrew Garfield and Toby Maguire
might be back in the MCU in Spider-Man 4
something that fans could be really
really excited for or a little bit
disappointed because we were looking
forward to our own Peter Parker our own
Spider-Man finally being on his own
however depending on the direction that
they are taking this we could be getting
both in the same movie right now it
sounds like it all depends on
Communications and negotiations between
Marvel Studios and Sony there are three
different directions that they could
take Spider-Man 4 and we'll break down
each Direction and what they could each
mean in this video and if you're new be
sure to subscribe so you don't miss out
on any of the latest Spider-Man and MCU
news we're also giving giving away a PS5
and Xbox series X more on the giveaway
at the end so according to a recent
report from Insider Daniel rpk Sony
Pictures is reportedly considering
bringing Toby Maguire and Andrew
Garfield back in Spider-Man 4 but here's
the deal here's the second part to this
Kevin foggy wants the movie to be more
grounded while Sony wants it to be huge
according to Daniel rpk now one could
see how Marvel Studios would want
Spider-Man 4 to be grounded but Sony
would want it to be absolutely huge the
biggest success for Spider-Man that Sony
has had is with Spider-Man being in the
MCU no doubt about that numbers don't
lie and a great vast majority of the
fans out there do like Tom Holland as
Spider-Man and I know a lot of people
would love to see Toby Maguire and
Andrew Garfield return but again like I
stated there are those people like Kevin
fige apparently who want a more grounded
film here's the deal though we are in
the Multiverse Saga and it's all
building up to all of these characters
ultimately colliding with each other
because the universe is collapsing
incursions are happening and universes
are going to come together so
considering what happened in Spider-Man
no way home and considering what is
going to happen in the Multiverse Saga
in the future and in Avengers Secret
Wars this storyline where Andrew
Garfield and Toby McGuire could show up
in Spider-Man 4 does make sense or I
should at least say it can make sense
with some decent storytelling which
leads us to our three options and I have
to say say I really hope it's option
three but we'll get to that in a bit and
once we go over them be sure to let me
know which option you would prefer in
the comments down below but option one
Marvel Studios gets their way now we
know Marvel Studios and Sony have
renegotiated a deal for Spider-Man in
the MCU and we don't really know all of
what that entails there hasn't been any
public information released about what
the deal was between them using
Spider-Man and the MCU we do know we
almost lost Spider-Man in the MCU a few
years ago luckily that didn't happen but
let's say Kevin fagy and Marvel Studios
have control over it and Sony doesn't
really get a say or for whatever reason
they all agree to let Spider-Man be a
more grounded film so option one we see
pretty much what we expected to see a
Spider-Man film where nobody knows who
Peter Parker is he is out on his own but
he has teammates or Allies on a side
from other superheroes like Daredevil
and Ant-Man who we've heard are going to
appear in the film Kingpin will be one
of the main villains of the film he will
be mayor of New York and he will make
being a vigilante illegal from there he
will disperse several villains to kind
of enforce this law with a focus on
Spider-Man because Spider-Man refuses to
obey this law so he wants him captured
from there we'll see a lot of different
villains Hammerhead and Tombstone are
rumored to be major villains of this
along with some others like maybe
scorpion but of course behind everything
is Kingpin it's also said that Miles
Morales is going to be introduced in
Spider-Man 4 to where he can ultimately
after years down the road after
Spider-Man 6 which is going to come
after Secret Wars after after the
Multiverse Saga Etc after Spider-Man 6
Tom Holland will hang up the webs and he
will retire as being Spider-Man and the
new Spider-Man in the MCU will be Miles
Morales during the film Ant-Man and
Daredevil will help Spider-Man
throughout this difficult time where
being a vigilante is illegal and that is
the reason for their cameos while at the
same time the street level heroes like
Daredevil the Punisher maybe Jessica
Jones maybe even more Defenders will all
be trying to go up against kingpin's
villains and take them down and
ultimately try to take him down as well
however it's already been clarified by
Marvel Studios that Kingpin is going to
be a big bad of the street level
Avengers so they're probably not going
to take him down in Spider-Man 4 it's
most likely going to be Spider-Man 6 and
that's option one what Marvel Studios
basically has planned right now they've
had planned all along but option two is
if Sony kind of gets their way and that
is to have another huge multiversal film
with the three Spider-Man in it now I
for one would welcome this if it was
done correctly and if it fit really well
into the multi verse Saga story and I'd
really like it to be tied back into
Spider-Man no way home there has to be a
good reason for them to come back into
Peter Parker's Universe our Peter Parker
that is unless they go absolutely crazy
and incursions start happening which
could very well be the case because we
knew that in Spider-Man the King Dynasty
which it was supposed to be we knew the
Avengers were going to lose and
incursions were going to start to happen
so since we've heard that Spider-Man 4
is going to come out before Avengers 5
now which it was supposed to come out
after originally but now that it's
coming out before that film we can start
to see incursions happen now and this
could bring back the other two
Spider-Man and they could work together
to try and figure out what is happening
they'd have to figure out a really good
villain for the three of them to fight
though and they'd have to have a pretty
big villain or multiple villains like
they did in the last film however I
think I would really enjoy watching the
three of them try to take on Kang or a
couple of different Kang variants this
would also have to have a bigger tie-in
directly into Avengers Secret Wars not
King Dynasty or Avengers 5 but Secret
Wars particularly because we've heard
that Andrew Garfield and Toby Maguire
are going to return for Avengers Secret
Wars and we've even heard that Toby
Maguire Spider-Man is going to be one of
the leads in that movie but if they're
bringing them back for Spider-Man 4 and
they want it to be a huge film where
they're involved the entire time I think
you have to have a pretty big Multiverse
story be the story of Spider-Man 4 but
that brings us to our third option which
is to kind of have a blend a little mix
of both and when I say A Little Mix I
don't actually mean 50/50 split I mean
probably about an 85 to 15% split
basically you only have Toby Maguire and
Andrew Garfield show up towards the end
because that's when all the real
Multiverse stuff starts to happen so
from the beginning of the movie till
basically the end you have a normal
Spider-Man movie what Kevin feige Marvel
Studios had planned for Spider-Man 4 to
be a grounded street level movie you
still have people like Ant-Man and
daredevil show up you have some Street
Heroes show up as well little cameos
here and there all serving a purpose of
course showing us the Vigilantes who
refuse to listen to Mayor kingpin's law
they're going to fight crime no matter
what especially when that crime is
coming from Kingpin himself we still
meet Miles Morales we still see
Spider-Man being on his own finally for
once we hear him listening to the police
scanner and going and fighting crimes on
the street he's truly on his own and
then they ultimately go up against
Kingpin or some of the big villains that
are under Kingpin and then towards the
end we see the Multiverse stuff start to
happen we see perhaps an incursion start
to happen and Earth 616 starts to
collide perhaps with another Earth or
another planet entirely that has
different people on it but this is where
you can have this film go directly into
Avengers the King Dynasty and when the
earth starts to collide with another
universe or maybe several other
universes this is where the other two
Spider-Man come into play because their
universes could be dealing with the same
problem and since they just dealt with a
multiversal let's call it problem in no
way home perhaps Toby could have sought
out Andrew or vice versa and the two of
them decided to go seek out Tom Holland
Spider-Man wondering if this has
anything to do with the events that just
took place in Spider-Man no way home
wondering if this is a doctor strange
issue or a spell issue but when they get
there they realize that it isn't this is
actually a huge Multiverse problem and
they want to figure out what it is this
is how they can dive into Kang Dynasty
and Avengers Secret Wars this could be
saved for the very end of Spider-Man 4
or even perhaps a post-credit scene
however if Sony wanted this movie to be
a huge Multiverse film that's probably
not going to be just a post-credit scene
but this could lead directly into Kang
Dynasty because in Kang Dynasty again
they're going to start to fight Kang
variants or at least that was the plan
before but we know the universe
essentially is going to collapse and
universes will be destroyed and collide
with each other and that should happen
in King Dynasty before Secret Wars so as
this happened happens I'm assuming
Andrew Garfield Spider-Man and Toby
Maguire's would go back to their own
universes and try to see if they could
do anything to help their own universes
from dying that way they wouldn't be in
Avengers King Dynasty and would have to
later return for Avengers Secret Wars
they can't pop up too much because then
it kind of loses its specialness so if I
had to pick I would definitely pick a
mixture of the two we could get both and
it could be done very well and it could
make sense story-wise Spider-Man 4 could
still pick up where Spider-Man no way
home left off in a few few ways we pick
up after Peter Parker's memory was
erased from everybody no one knows who
he is he's on his own he's fighting
street level crime he's making new
friends Miles Morales being one of them
but of course people remember who
Spider-Man still is so we have Daredevil
and Ant-Man coming to his side not as
mentors but as allies we see Spider-Man
fight some street level bosses then
after Toby McGuire and Andrew Garfield
show up talk about how their universes
are collapsing we see that our main
universe is starting to collapse and
then we go right into King Dynasty I'd
love to see this not because I would
love to see the three Spider-Man on
screen again which I absolutely would
but continuity wise and story-wise it
makes sense it makes sense for the two
other Spider-Man to seek each other out
and then seek Tom Holland Spider-Man out
because they're wondering if the same
thing that happened in no way home is
happening again only to realize that no
this is a huge multiversal threat the
Council of Kings is coming they need to
protect their universes and the
Multiverse in general I think it makes a
lot of sense and I would love to see it
but go ahead and let me know your
thoughts about this in the comments down
below would you like any of these
options or would you like something
completely different leave your thoughts
down below please don't forget to like
this video And subscribe to the channel
to stay up to date on the MCU and
Spider-Man and if you subscribe and
leave a comment you're automatically
entered in our giveaway for a chance to
win a PS5 an Xbox series X some Marvel
Legends items or some DC items the
winner gets to pick one item and we pick
one winner at the end of each month as
always thank you all so much for
watching woof
woof